I'm sure all of you watch the testimony
of dr. Ford judge Cavanaugh and his
confirmation hearings today and I got to
tell you if you're like me I we all
watched it here everybody had it on it
was extremely stressful and emotional
and dramatic so watching that all day
long and I was thinking to myself
literally all day throughout the day how
do we make a funny show tonight like how
do we do that yeah how do you make it
after you watch all that how do you make
a funny show tonight and then I had this
really inspiring thought I've been doing
this for 25 years and we've made plenty
of shows that weren't funny a lot I mean
come on right spring of 2012
wake the whole spring oh you don't
remember there were years at a time
where we were just whoo I thought I
realized that I was like the pressures
off for us lutely sure what this could
just be another one of those show yeah
so with that in mind I thought maybe
would start the show tonight with just
silly jokes that these are real news
stories that just have no point are you
cool with that no point at all no
bearing right right because I think
that's what the country's come to expect
from us everyone else on TV is gonna be
talking about that tonight and how
upsetting it is but if people want to
completely miss the point of everything
they should be here right yeah yeah I
gotta check out that Conan idiot
Shia LaBeouf and his wife are divorcing
Shia LaBeouf and his wife are divorcing
after a relatively short marriage you
had a marriage ended when the wife said
wait you're that Shia LaBeouf it could
be a problem that could be right back
and then she cut out of it has anyone
ever crept away going like that
except in my imagination I think that's
how Dracula cry Dracula at a zoo in
California man tried to climb into a
lion enclosure and was bitten in the
foot by the lion
man was taken to the hospital where his
condition was listed as stupid city of
Los Angeles
there's no transitions here I think the
city of Los Angeles is a true story is
trying to crack down on illegal
cockfighting yeah in response the mayor
of West Hollywood said you mean the bird
right
[Applause]
it was down here I I missed the ball
you